If I follow label directions and take two caps of clear digest before each meal, how long does my acid state elevate it?
If I have a snack, should I take one camp?
No, this...
Drinking vegetable fruit, not smoothie, including fiber.
Throughout six to seven hours, today should I take pop a capsule every few hours?
I do have bloating, that is bothersome, but it is there, I think, from the smoothie fiber.
Okay, that's a great leading question to the last question we had, or follow-up question to the last question.
So clear digest is HCl and digestive enzymes and some other things bile and such.
So it's there to help you digest your food, but what if you're drinking a smoothie all day long?
Should you just be popping these throughout the day?
Yes, possibly, that would be a good thing to do.
If it's just you don't want to take HCl on an empty stomach, because it would be sitting in there with no food in your stomach, and it could irritate your stomach possibly, especially if you already have damaged stomach wall.
That's why, if you look at the blog post on hypochloridory, it does state that if you try a product like clear digest or a product that has HCl in it, and it hurts your stomach really bad, that is a red flag that you already have damaged to the lighting of your stomach, maybe even a full ulcer.
So then you have to back off on that, it's too much and we have to go to either, you know, all the way back to try to heal the light of the stomach with taking deaclyceride licorice and slippery element, things like that.
Or go back one step and take a little milder acid and ample cider vinegar.
However, in this question, this question is saying, okay, if I'm eating, first of all, how long has the acid stayed elevated in my stomach after I take clear digest?
Well, it depends on how much food you're putting in there afterwards.
So if you're taking two near clear digest, let's say, and you eat a meal and then, you know, half hour later, you're going to drink some of your smoothie, there may not be any left in there at that time.
Because the HCl is being used, it's helping to break down that food that was in there. So therefore it makes sense that if you're going to eat just a real small meal, you may be only taking one.
If you're going to eat a bigger meal, you take two. If you're eating something that you know, you already have difficult issues with digestion, let's say I'm going to eat a steak.
That I always know that if I eat a steak, it kind of sits in my gut, while I might take four, you know, what I'm going to eat something that may be more difficult to digest.
So you would you would base it based upon what you're eating and how much you're eating.
Secondly, I want to address a heated part of this question. You're getting possibly getting bloating with fiber in your drink.
So if I don't know if this is the case because it's not really the full question, but it brought something to mind.
Let's say a person is taking a fiber supplement. Let's say they're taking some fiber or some spectrum.
And when they do that, they feel really bloated after that. Well, that's a sign that you probably should back off of the fiber.
If you eat a fiber supplement or a fiber product or you're eating something with a lot of fiber in it, and it's causing, you know, bad bloating, that can be a sign of small intestinal bacterial over growth.
So that's just something to keep in the back of your mind. If you're like, well, no, it's not that bad. It helps if I take a digestive enzyme.
That's fine, but you may want to back off of the fiber and see if that changes the bloating because that's one test that you could kind of self do for SIBO.
Small intestinal bacterial over growth is does fiber make you worse? If it does, then kind of to re-adoculate your small intestine before you add fiber back.
Something to keep in mind. But the real question is, should you take clear digest with smaller meals? Should you take clear digest with some smoothie that's your dry kids are all today? Yes.
Can you maybe an extension of this question? Could you take too much of it? Yes, but you would get a, if you took too much HCl, you'd get a stomach ache right at the bottom of your ribs or at the bottom of your sci-foid process.
So that would be the only thing. And if you took, if you took even one or two and you got that stomach ache, that would tell us that you might have something else, you know, other damage to your stomach.
That would be for people who are just starting to take an HCl product. There's a lot of people that have got issues.
We recommend clear digest or an HCl product. They start taking it and it hurts way worse. That's a sign that they quite possibly have.
And also we have to back off on that and follow the protocol that I listed that blog post on hypochloridria to heal the stomach first.